[Musique]
merci Didier accueillas dans le village
de l'entre-deux qu'au sol a pousse azote
à faire la musique parce que la pousse à
nous a fait à la musique avant tout
c'est la passion déjà la passion nous
baigne dedans depuis nous les mamans et
particulièrement le reggae la tombe de
la marmite quand il dit
le reggae avant tout c'est clair à la
nous c'est déjà la vibration la
vibration les positive comme il dit dans
le morceau et ensuite on en a aussi
les paroles souvent les thèmes abordés
que ce soit des thèmes où ça où
revendiquent un peu des choses mais
aussi des paysages on parle de la nature
tout ça c'est en fait la richesse des
thèmes abordés que il y aura la nuit
aussi dans cette musique si vous êtes
[Musique]
sentier le dé à la liberté vous sera
comblé nous va bien apprécié nous va
bien y est est-ce qu'on peut expliquer à
nous ça il vient le nom du groupe
youngoruts
yango c'est du vieux créole qui veut
dire cool Gaia et c'est en discutant
avec Luciano du groupe comme ça un des
piliers du reggae à la Réunion c'est du
Chano donne la soufano un petit peu
l'idée noter pour eux d'un nom et du
coup bah yangourou tu la venue comme une
évidence parce que c'est quelque chose
que un peu rare comme nous il nous dit
plus trop ce genre de mots comme elle a
et route parce que c'est le style
musical reggae que noirfectionne
particulièrement le route c'est un peu à
l'ancienne me direz et en même temps
root s'il veut dire aussi racine donc
c'est aussi on a aussi les racines
dedans les racines du reggae et
justement est-ce que je tiens porte pas
une touche un peu personnelle dans dans
cette musique reggae mais en tout cas
nous essaye nous essayent en fait chacun
des musiciens
donnant des influences différentes on
peut avoir des influences un peu soul un
peu de jazzy un peu Degué aussi donc
tout ça nous essaye mélange Ali et du
coup bah il donne il donne la Réunion
[Musique]
dans mon cœur dans mon tapis résonne
le good vibrer
[Musique]
comment où la tombe dans la musique dans
la musique
à l'adolescence elle avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de matté déjà un mélomane on va
dire mais après le côté musical même
c'est comme à la découvre Bob Marley
voilà voulu approfondir un peu ces
textes qu'on connaitre que ça il y a
pour raconter donc du coup ben comment
se traduit un petit peu et moi comment
je guitare aussi en même temps
[Musique]
et comme ça où il y aimerait pour la
suite pour ce groupe là qu'est-ce que
est-ce que ça donne un rêve en
particulier
en fait
le rêve peut-être ce serait de voyager
ensemble un jour voilà
mais déjà rien que de donne du plaisir
aux gens à chacun de nos concerts déjà
ça vraiment il donne à nous beaucoup de
bonnes au coeur et c'est ça que nous
nous principales satisfaction en fait
c'est le partage musical entre le public
et nous de voir de Moon il arrive dans
une conseiller il oublie cette problème
elle est en train de chanter avec nous
un entraîne apprécier ça vraiment c'est
on va dire le but ultime mais nous les
comptons quand nous voir à ça en fait
[Musique]